the 14 bedroom maze on the macia is a
small boutique hotel located in the
border town of las cruces new mexico it
should be a wonderful southwestern oasis
but the few guests that visit the hotel
are in for an unpleasant surprise
owner kelly chavinsky purchased the
former bed and breakfast in 2006 and
completely remodeled it putting her own
distinctive taste and style into every
aspect from the food to the furnishings
to me it's very european it's very
tuscan in nature maybe that's the
venetian plaster but i didn't really
pick a style as much as i just picked
out things that i liked and one thing
kelly likes a lot is beige the bedroom's
a beige with beige and a little beige
the walls are freaky it looks like it's
trying to be marble but it's
plastic i do not believe the customer is
always right definitely not a place that
i would feel comfortable staying
sometimes they're wrong
well
pregnant she wanted to make sure it was
well you know the more you cook it the
less flavor you'll have
how's that chicken parm tinder salad
going callie made the menu we only
served tuscan food i don't even know if
callie's ever been to italy 86
bruschetta told you guys forever that
was an awful recipe
but it may not be the bad food or the
decor that's keeping guests away
my mother was a bartender and she would
have me sing to people and they paid
attention to me they liked me i live for
applause kelly tried to make it as a
professional singer but when her career
stalled she found her own personal
concert venue i bought the hotel to sing
the audience members really like me a
lot i'm like an
audio mirage you if if i do a share tune
you're going to think you're here and
share if you're not looking at me you
think i am sure
we get a lot of telephone calls it's
cali singing tonight well then that kind
of means they like too proud to tell you
why i was wrong i think i surprised them
quite a bit because they just don't
expect it
give me just a second here
after that song i need a little drink
two months ago kelly hired local
restauranteur steinberg as her new
general manager ladies how are we
let's check who's checking in zan's wife
mitzi has been working with kelly since
the hotel opened in the beginning my
husband zan and callie's relationship
was very good has it deteriorated oh
bunch
where are the keys how can i get
anything done if that bastard won't put
[ __ ] back
dan is the biggest problem here right
now and that's unfortunate because i
brought him on to help me with what i
thought the biggest problem was was we
don't have enough customers some kind of
general manager he is cali should be
fired for being a poor operator and
digging this thing into a hole
with ownership and management not on the
same page the guests are the ones that
suffer how is everything here
we're basically ready to get our wood to
go because we waited so long okay let me
take care of this one cali believes that
the customers have a place in her hotel
but cali's at the tippy top of that
pyramid i do not enjoy going up the
tables and having something wrong at
every [ __ ] table i go to yes
i don't like it at all
hotel bookings have fallen to an
all-time low and for much of the year
not one of the 14 bedrooms has a guest
in if things don't change fast the hotel
will be forced to close someone needs to
be able to tell me what it is i'm doing
wrong
everything that i have is tied up into
the hotel
i need gordon's help badly
my first time in new mexico
i'm in las cruces in the southwest
desert and look at it i mean absolutely
stunning on the way to the maison de
macia now this is a small boutique hotel
possibly the perfect getaway you have
arrived at your destination you're
kidding me
i mean this is a joke you've arrived
yeah i've got a [ __ ] pile of sand
turn around when possible it's crazy
it doesn't make sense you have arrived
at your destination is that it there
turn around turn around
you think they have a decent sign on
there wouldn't you it's like a prison
finally
hello hello and welcome to my santa
masia good to see you so whose favorite
color is beige
well cali was the decorator kelly is the
cali is the owner yeah it runs this is
our cleaning agreement if you could read
and sign it please cleaning agreement
yes just so you don't i'm not coming for
a job or
damage
a
property this is a damage your property
yes the owner is very concerned about
the venetian plaster
the owner is very concerned about the
venetian plaster
and she wants me to sign a waiver yes
they said i won't damage it yes sir does
everyone have to sign these everyone yes
why would i sign a waiver i'm not sure
why you'd want to sign a waiver
no sir i'm not going to sign that by the
way welcome good to see you what a first
impression i don't believe that there
needs to be a waiver i just do what i'm
told you put all these things on there
it doesn't look like new mexico to me it
sure doesn't maybe italian uh well i
have two russians in italy and my
russians haven't got pictures of new
mexico
bloody hell let's go up to the room
do i have to sign a waiver to walk on
the carpet no sir look that was not me
looks like someone's pooped on my wall
oh
got a little fireplace a fireplace
that's exactly what you need in the
middle of the [ __ ] desert jeopardy
alternate rooms i'd love to move if it
was less beige all the rooms are going
to be the same oh [ __ ] oh thank you i'm
gonna pack you're gonna leave me alone
on my own in my room do i need to sign a
waiver no sir no nice to meet you by the
way nice to meet you too gordon thank
you
this room is so bland it looks more like
an airport hotel than a fun weekend
getaway in the heart of new mexico i
can't wait to meet the woman behind this
hello hi
welcome to the sun go on
um i thought that you'd be wearing beige
with a lady that's in love with beige
everywhere i do like beige my favorite
color is beige but i think beige goes
with a lot of things i didn't sign the
waiver sending that message out to every
customer coming in here is not a good
sign to begin with well it's 7.50 cents
a square foot to replace the venetian
plaster so it can be a lot if someone
does some damage why don't you uh show
me around i would love to show you
around
this is the main dining room how many
cities do i have eighty-nine would you
have a stairs it's a stage where i
perform oh wow amazing and percussionist
guitars no it's actually right now i
sing the tracks so you have like a
backing track and you sing over this yes
i do okay
wow wow
and this is the bar this is the bar over
there we have another stage i usually
sing in here on fridays and sounds and
who else performs here
no one else
no
wow wow and then through here
seriously what's all that [ __ ] in the
pool well that's from the pool cleaner
who was supposed to be here this morning
it's a little bit late is it busy the
pool no it's not very talented people
usually
mind you i suppose it's like going for a
swim in a prison jesus christ
what's on the back now
that was for entertainment oh my god
three stages i sing everywhere in the
hotel
i love to sing period
three stages i hope there's no stage in
the kitchen
hello hi how are you good sierra here
angel sarah nice to see you likewise
where are you from i'm from new mexico
oh nice local guys
excellent is the cuisine uh new mexico
yes there's nothing here that's new
mexican at all no
this is all very uh
confusing i'm looking forward to tasting
the food later anyway whatever it is uh
let's catch up with a bar shall we
nicely nice to meet you too i like to
cook southwestern cuisine like i don't
know why we have tuscan food
as the owner in your mind what's wrong
with the place well we don't have enough
customers and you've had it now since
2006. how much did it cost 1.2 million
wow and that's what i purchased it for
how much did you spend converting
another 1.2
2.5 million
bloody hell i shut down for 14 months to
remodel it 14 months shut down yeah it
wasn't supposed to be 14 months it was
supposed to be four it turned it into 14
months and a million two to do it and
the contractor was indicted bloody how
i've gone through a lot of stuff with
this hotel it's like i'm starting to
think maybe the problem is i'm just too
trusting
how long can you continue putting money
in
i've got
maybe
60 70 70 000 left so for the next six
months max
yeah unless unless we unless it kicks up
um listen i'm uh i'm here to help
and i'm sorry it's been this difficult
thank you i'm glad to see i'm i'm really
glad you're here
i've just arrived at maison de mesa and
i'm confused by this hotel who put all
these things on there it doesn't look
like new mexico to me it sure doesn't i
met cali the owner and she told me she's
desperate for this place to succeed i'm
really glad
so i'm keen to meet the general manager
and see why he's letting this place fail
on his watch now you're the general
manager i'm the general manager um how
long have you been working in hotels
hotels would be nine weeks i said i'd
never been in a hotel but i'd always
been in restaurants full service
restaurants how does a russian manager
become qualified to be a general manager
of a hotel when you've never worked in a
hotel before it's not that complicated
take care of the guests check it out
that complicates it
i don't believe it is i can do the work
it's not that hard there's only like six
seven things i need to learn what are
the major problems major problems callie
is the owner she's the major major
problem she is too controlling and my
hands are being tied if you're not being
allowed to do the job you came in to do
why are you here
i'm here because i'm emotionally
invested in the place
well my wife's been here all these years
anytime somebody calls in sick the first
person they call is mitzi we've always
thought it's a gold mine we just can't
figure out why we can't get people in
the seats the only way for mison to be
successful is for cali to back out what
are these things here uh the vinyl we're
uh disgusting
in fact can we take this off do you mind
instantly it looks better right do not
need to be a general manager to make
that decision do you no is there a
server or i'm gonna bring a server over
here please and his or her name uh mitty
mitty is your wife yes how are you good
how are you let's order first shall we
okay and then we'll have a chat all
right what would you like
we are in new mexico aren't we yes we
are in las vegas
taste of tuscany yes why wouldn't you
just go for a modern stunning delicious
mexican cuisine i guess it's because she
thinks there's enough of them it's crazy
uh the proscetta looks good okay
the chicken piccata that sounds
interesting okay the lamb lollipops wow
it's not cheap is it 23 for the lamb
lollipops
thank you my dog
bloody how
i got the person
i know good food thank you so much no
problem our food is really good
to be forewarned it's not the cash
shower on my plate bruschetta normally
goes with uh tomatoes yes and this is
olives and anchovies popular dish
um no
it's like vomit though i guess
dear idea words got out that i'm in town
and the restaurant is starting to fill
up with customers
i feel sorry for all of them
wow here we go my 23 lollipops being the
longest member staff here what do you
think's wrong with this place
um i think kelly's reputation is it that
bad
she's rude she's rich
she's brass she's short she's not
flexible you think you get the picture
thank you
blimey not what i'd call a loyal
workforce
fat
23
dreadful
tough as [ __ ]
do you like lamb i love lamb it's tough
perhaps a little rare a little tough
what is going on no you haven't got much
hotel experience but isn't this your
forte restaurants yes bloody hell i'm
finished with that thank you
i mean dreadful absolutely you can tell
it is the lamb frozen the lamb comes
frozen and we thought of course you find
out where it's from
yes
lamb lollipops no go
so far nothing i've it has even a remote
connection to the area nothing local
nothing authentic nothing new mexican
new zealand
new zealand lamb wow
that part's right that part's right
our chicken is um picada's
non-traditional thank you for visiting
us here at vasanti macia my name is
callie i'm gonna do just a little music
for you this afternoon little rock
number from share
if i could reach the stars
i'd give them all to you
then you love me
i'm not too sure what's more scary the
food or the singing what would you say
um
and thanks for joining us here
is that normal
yes that's not just because i'm here
no
she is not cher
i am sorry i love this thing that's
probably why i bought this place
i've got to get away from this
horrendous singing
we haven't met you have we say again sir
we haven't met you have we no sir i'm
david david what'd you do yes sir i'm a
pantry pantry yes
are you trying david well it's trained a
little bit sir i've been around sir and
where's your love of food coming from
where where'd you father your family
that's a chef no sir my dad was a nurse
but he loved to eat wow
walking in another calamari with the rim
you lot i have the second calamari
selling right now ma'am hey give just
two seconds it's it's already breaded
i'm enough right right now sir that's
already cooked yes sir
so when was it cooked oh actually we get
in a boxer we get it from a fish company
sir completely frozen just touch that oh
yes sir it feels like rubber i i don't
eat the fish here sir how come you know
this and you're still doing it my
opinion doesn't matter in this
restaurant you know it's bad yes and yet
you just i guess you will do it
life
wow i hope tonight's guest can remain as
positive as david has if you can sign
this here for me it's just a cleaning
agreement a what a cleaning agreement
just in case you do throw red wine on
our walls does that happen it has
happened actually
unfortunately the guests checking in are
getting the same terrible welcome that i
did i could please have you read good
evening ladies welcome
nice to see you both thank you i'd like
to apologize about the waiver all right
well you got to do oh oh oh
no throwing red wine on the walls true
sign cleaning agreement yeah so what
does that mean like do the check off
list when you come in and then do the
checkoff list when you exit in the
morning
is there any other breakfast other than
coffee in the morning no ma'am there's
no breakfast is there a room service or
anything no ma'am you're lucky you're
not hearing the singing i'm going to
head to the bar for a quiet afternoon
any more singing and i feel like my head
might explode okay what is going on
customers are having dinner and all of a
sudden she breaks into this music
totally unexpected no totally yeah she
just sits there and absolutely wasn't it
yeah um what the [ __ ] seriously i've
seen enough for one day just you're
gonna have to lay that down somewhere
where's she going now she's just gonna
sing
no guys
yes sir you are kidding me i thought
these guests in here were the lucky ones
they did do the same numbers exact same
she's a nut challenge exactly yes my
name is callie for those of you who
don't know i do a little entertaining
here got any share fans in the audience
with dinner service and the terrible
karaoke concert finally over it's time
to get the chef and the management
together and find out what on earth is
going on here
let's get one thing absolute certain it
is not a taste of tuscany it's not funny
so [ __ ]
so are you are you proud of this no i
just told you because i'm not allowed to
change anything
oh my god i feel like there is many
pricing issues here there are definitely
changes that have to happen
you're amazing
it's just total horseshit it's just
total horseshit you know it's just like
no we work within the constraints and
i'm allowed to organize immediately this
should all have been kind of yes we
should have it all constraints my ass
you have done nothing since you came in
here but talk about me behind my back
try to set me up to fail every [ __ ]
day why do i want to make you look i
don't know i wish the hell i did know
but i've got several people we can line
up and we'll tell them exactly what you
said to us i imagine we will you know i
can hear the same thing about you
i'll leave and the only thing you'll say
the parting words not to me is i hope he
hangs himself
how horrible is that when i'm doing an
event here well i'll tell you how
horrible it is about as horrible as when
somebody hires all new people and tells
each and every one of them that she's a
[ __ ] to work for you can't work either
but hang in there because in six months
i'll be running this place and she'll be
gone i mean literally right out of the
box right out of the box so there you go
it goes back to you yeah because that's
when i found out what an untrustworthy
backstabbing son of a [ __ ] you are
i gotta worry about my back
continuously with you watson this major
miracle man that was supposed to come in
here and double and triple this business
when there's been no change whatsoever
none was i allowed to make any changes
like direct dramatically you wanted to
you wanted to hire new people what you
did each and every one of them that they
shouldn't work for me god's sake is that
true
there was the impression given that
callie would no longer be here whenever
she owns the place why were you
suggesting that she's not going to be
here after sierra starts
i don't recall that
poor [ __ ] wow it just wasn't her it
wasn't her it was annie
does the general manager bad mouth the
owner
behind her back yes
of course she doesn't trust you if
you're going to bad now behind your back
if you were the owner what would you do
i would fire that person that bad mouth
me
you're fired
i think i'm leaving
i was just fired
no callie i'm sorry you've already
failed and you need a fall guy okay you
got me you run it you step up to the
plate good luck i'm leaving too i'm out
of here i feel betrayed
and if the [ __ ] thinks i'm gonna stay
she's nuts
you know i don't mind callie yelling at
me it's fine she finally got it off her
[ __ ] chest but she doesn't trust
anybody you know everybody's burned her
in her history i don't know i didn't
burn her
it felt good to fire him because it's
been a cancer here at the hotel now the
tumor has been cut out and we're going
to be in better shape
zan's just been fired and the level of
animosity and the friction between those
two is extraordinary but the question is
what happens next
i had a rough night's sleep with that
bloody share tune going round and round
my head i'm hoping i can wash that tune
out of my brain with a quick swim and
that's not all i'd like to forget
my first day at maison was crazy within
hours of my arrival the general manager
was fired what an untrustworthy
backstabbing son of a [ __ ] you are
and i turned your torture by kalyoke i
really didn't mean to hurt you
today has got to be better than
yesterday let's hope the poor guy came
the pool is still dirty
what the hell is that
oh joke
i mean what a badly
utilized space i mean
you think of a hotel anywhere in new
mexico
god
one thing is an asset
this is pool i mean this space could be
the best thing about this hotel yeah
it's just abused
dirty not even a town out here so
what the [ __ ] which i'm in
there that's disgusting
breakfast so no morning swim for me but
at least i can enjoy a good breakfast to
start the day
oh my god
that's all they've got to offer how
depressing is that this is crazy i've
got to find some breakfast i'm starving
and cold coffee isn't going to do it but
i've heard there's an amazing farmers
market in town so
i'm going to quickly check it out
what lovely little place i've heard
david from maison's kitchen runs a food
truck here in his spare time no deep
fried calamari i hope i saw the lion i
thought wow what are you serving we got
quesadillas the best in new mexico okay
brilliant i have a little food truck
with a buddy of mine chris a little
taste of new mexico
this is one of our favorites right here
the cucumber lime that's perfect
but 100 degrees outside that's perfect
right
my goodness wow that's delicious so
what's in the case there cheese green
chili and aceto cheese here you are my
friend thank you
hmm
that was delicious yeah david that's
better than anything i've eaten in the
hotel you know that
delicious thank you the food truck is my
creative outlet it's a place for me to
at least express my ideas without having
any borders well done i'll see you later
good job delicious enjoy guys thank you
this town is stunning full of charm and
local colour it's such a shame the hotel
reflects none of that i've got to find a
way to get kali to embrace new mexico
and make the most of what her hotel has
to offer how you feeling
i'll go okay i think it's important for
you to
understand the bigger picture okay yeah
kick in with me please thank you
hopefully what i have planned will open
kelly's eyes
kelly this is
some of your guests
i'd like you to share your experiences
why don't we stand up with you first
please
first impressions are important to me
and the very first thing i had to do was
sign a cleaning waiver
and it just it makes the assumption that
i'm not going to be clean that
assumption was it was just a tough first
impression yes a valid point waivers are
for bungee jumps are you apparel
that whole thing for me wasn't to make
you think that i didn't think that you
were clean it was i had someone come in
and throw red wine all over the venetian
plaster and i thought that i should
charge them for that but you're
punishing every other guest
of one guest and it's not right you know
you can't penalize future business on
the back of one idiot
so
it appears that there's no flat into
what the customer is going to experience
for instance um the first thing on a hot
day you want to go into the pool
and we looked out to the pool and in
it's right now it's the same way it's
got um a lot of leaves and it's dirty so
maybe it's not open but how can it not
be open yes the valley point man please
we were in the lounge for dinner and
when you were singing we couldn't have a
conversation it's just not appropriate
for
an upscale intimate fine dining
experience i feel like you're very
focused on the performance but you're
not really focused on your guests
very interesting so
anything that goes wrong with the
restaurant when you're singing you're
too busy singing and not caring about
your guests
i would pay you 100 bucks
not to sing
as long as you are focused on your
singing career and not on your
restaurant and hotel career
my wife and i won't be back
i don't agree i have quite a bit of
people that come here to hear me saying
guest feedback is critical it's about
turning that negativity into something
positive now i'd like to introduce you
to a very special lady neelu matamet she
is the features director and the senior
correspondent for travel and leisure
magazine
nina um give us an insight to your stay
please
one of the things that we look at is
whether a hotel has a sense of place
whether it's maximizing the value that
that beautiful setting that it's in has
you mentioned the pool
that's one great example of a moment
where you have a potential great asset
here that is being
underutilized and it's kind of
underwhelming there's a reason why hotel
schools exist so it's not a hobby it's a
business
there is one question i'd like to ask
you all would you come back to stay in
this hotel again please raise your hands
no one
um thank you to you all your feedback
has been absolutely pivotal i appreciate
it
i was sending a message
that i didn't realize i was sending and
didn't want to send i want people to
come here i want them to feel welcomed
are you starting to understand i am you
are i am
you're worrying about the wrong things
the
biggest
issue you have is understanding who's
number one the guests have to be number
one
not kelly that's that's that's the
bottom line if you can change that
this place has every chance of becoming
a big success
can you change
happy
i will help you
but you've got
to start this thing i can do it
i can
i hope so
it's been a tough week at mace on the
messiah but i believe callie is finally
committed to putting her guests first i
can do it
i can
so overnight my design team have pulled
off an incredible transformation which i
can't wait to share with kelly and her
staff are we ready
please turn around
wow a stunning sign
now when you drive by it tells you what
we are missandei messi a hotel or
restaurant gorgeous right very beautiful
now everybody that goes by is not going
to wonder huh i wonder whose nice house
that is
are you ready to see inside
because this you're going to absolutely
love
morning everybody how are you oh wait
cool
welcome to your new hotel breakfast
buffet wow remember what breakfast used
to be like we had cold coffee now you
have a very traditional stunning
breakfast buffet that will be serving
crisp white linens not those horrible
plastic cloths and that's not all i
reached out and got an amazing local
talented breakfast chef let me introduce
you
meet david our breakfast chef wow david
hi david hey thank you
that's a wonderful thing i feel great
right now i'm loving the recipes and i'm
i'm really excited to be in the kitchen
right now
kelly yes sir i think that's a much
better way of using that stage than a
kalyoke evening
let's go
welcome
to new suite
very cool
what's in there it's very cool
wow very very cool
so we've incorporated some of the local
colors
and brought them in to this boutique
hotel cali
how you feeling
amazed room 205 is is an amazing amazing
room it's a new mexico
feel i don't know it's not bait but you
don't mind do you no no not at all i
think it's gorgeous i do the walls are
still beautiful and yet we have all this
color and it goes so well with the area
that we're in
i've added color but there's something
i've taken away there are no more
waivers for your guests to sign is that
good with you callie good
it's awesome the front desk no longer
has waivers and the new rooms are
colorful they fit with exactly where we
are in this historic district i am very
proud to show people the new rooms i've
got one very small thing to show you you
ready we are this you're gonna love
oh it's out here
oh my god
oh my gosh
that's amazing that's awesome
now that's what i call a pool yes it is
remember there was leaves and crap
everywhere now welcome to one of the
hippiest one of the coolest pools
anywhere in new mexico that is the oasis
in the middle of the day
gone is that hideous fence and replaced
it with new turf and pool furniture to
die for
beautiful
it is
it is
people will just want to come and hang
out here now man bam this is awesome the
pool absolutely beautiful never seen
anything like it if we don't have pool
parties now then something's wrong this
is your fantastic cabana area
gun is the stage if you want to sing
kelly do it in the shower
can i have a margarita carlos
i'll be serving a lot of drinks out here
i'm hoping the business is going to
absolutely kick off with this wonderful
pool
now that you have a stunning
outside area
let me introduce you to your new
poolside menu wow
so you start off with a lovely
refreshing tomato gazpacho beautifully
marinated seasoned lovely with extra
virgin olive oil fish tacos as well oh
i'm gonna eat all that yes
and delicious fruit kebabs well this is
great wonderful fresh fruit mango orange
lime coconut and seasoned with those
wonderful green local chilis a taste of
new mexico not tuscany kelly
outstanding the tomato gazpacho is is
magnificent i'm very proud to cook this
food it makes sense and it goes with new
mexico and i think it's excellent have a
good look at the menu get used to it
because we're going to be pushing it big
time
see you in a minute this makeover is the
biggest i've done in any of the hotels
i've visited there's over 150 000 worth
of upgrades and i've never been happier
with the improvements it's exactly what
the guests need if i was kelly i'd be
over the moon
green chilies pecans everything that new
mexico is about we have it on the menu
we have the guacamole we have the salsa
what do i do with the five cases of
hamburger buns that i just brought in
and and even more hey we want to spend
an hour putting things away every night
and then bring them out every morning
this is what ramsay gave the hotel on
flavor labor labor labor
who do i hire to do that this is a lot
of work
i can't i can't i love dance
deal with it
oh my god there's things that i'm
concerned about the pool is outstanding
it's scary to me because i've got a
pretty big job ahead of me now and the
linens major pain in the ass
so many things that i'm gonna have to do
that right now you know i'm really like
freaking out over these and uh what i'm
gonna do is raise prices
cali is a little overwhelmed right now i
do believe she likes the fact that it's
more new mexican jesus god almighty but
callie's cali where's all my [ __ ]
where's all my [ __ ] what does that mean
the all the other stuff that you took
away all right what stuff tell me
the tapestries oh and i know you took
down all the grapes yes it was covered
in a pretty big hole in that wall all
right let's show me
show me what we oh it's like this yeah
is that what you're worried about is a
plastic bunch of grapes to hide this
where somebody hit it with a table we
can get your grapes back and you can
stick plastic breaks back on the wall
let me show you something for two
seconds i want to show you something
really important
just have a look at that out there how
beautiful is that gorgeous it's exactly
what your guests need and want
let me show you something
oh there it is look at that amazing
stuff there and i look at this pile of
[ __ ] in here and you're starting to
create a fuss
forgetting that this hotel is about the
guess and you start putting the team on
edge because you want plastic grapes
here's what i'm going to do for you
in 15 minutes i will clear all that
furniture okay and i'll put it back in
my van and this [ __ ] here i'll put back
in there
let me show you something
oh there it is look at that amazing
stuff there and i look at this pile of
[ __ ] in here and you're starting to
create a fuss here's what i'm gonna do
for you
in 15 minutes i will clear all that
furniture okay and i'll put it back in
my van and this [ __ ] here i'll put back
in there
i am i am ex
should we go should we get in there and
look for your grapes no okay i am
more grateful than you can because we
have a very bizarre way of showing it
that's all
thank you kelly
sometimes what i say with the best
intentions is taken with the worst and
to be aware of that is very good because
that just means that i'm going to be
able to start thinking the thought all
the way through
before that comes out of my mouth
i'm glad kelly's grateful but i am
worried as soon as i leave she'll be
back to her old ways plastic greggs
won't kill her business but if she
carries on singing that might you
mustn't take this the wrong way and i
hope you don't but i grew up with a dad
that was
constantly
moving our family in and out of working
men's clubs bars and singing every
[ __ ] weekend
seeing him ruin his life trying to be
someone who's never gonna be
the other night i watched you move from
here to here oh christ
you shouldn't be doing this in here i
think there's a level of class about you
the way you hold yourself the way you
dress the way you you appear i don't
want to see you
being
laughed at
i really don't know how to to uh to
react but obviously um
every time you're singing you're not
very hot i totally agree with you right
now
it needs to be run
okay that makes sense to me okay okay
i think kelly's ready for a fresh start
so i invited lots of new guests and a
local band for maison's first ever pool
party
hi
table four four five fifteen fifteen
fifteen
the pool party crowds are loving all the
changes the fish tacos are yummy that's
awesome they're loving the food guys yes
keep it going yes you know my first job
when i was 18 hot wash starters running
but i wasn't running to glamorous pools
like you're about to run to
and then you guests are loving the
colorful rooms
it's beautiful this is beautiful
no that's coming
i think this will work
people will like this idea
it's really neat to have something like
this in las vegas because there's
nothing like this we don't have to leave
town we're here vacation
i think kelly's heart is in the right
place but she has a lot to learn about
running her hotel i'd like to introduce
you to a very special man mr jeff mayhem
nice to meet you likewise how are you
doing i'm wonderful now this man has a
wealth of experience spanning nearly
three decades of running some of the
most prestigious and luxurious boutique
hotels in new mexico jeff's a former
innkeeper of the year he's not just good
he's one of the best
and he knows this business inside out
after all he does something so well that
he's incapable of the year i want my
guest to get the experience that his
guests get i'm gonna leave you two alone
spend some valuable time thank you okay
great we look forward to working with
her thank you
so let's talk okay
now kelly clearly she can't turn back
time but she can insist on this place
having a bright future in one condition
she stays off that bloody microphone and
makes her guess the stars
and not that bloody singing
can she do it
that's the million dollar question
it's the end of a long week at maison de
mesa i'm really happy with the changes
at the hotel but it could still all fall
apart if instead of stepping up as
general manager kelly steps back onto
the stage it's time for me to say
goodbye if you have that little urge
that you start getting the tremors and
you feel a need
for the mic
i want you to run into the freezer
stay there two seconds
i put your microphone in a block of ice
now
this
will give you
two or three hours to defrost which will
give you a chance to understand that the
guests are the stars
i understand i want you to see these
changes and run this stunning boutique
hotel i will thank you thank you
i found out from gordon i don't have a
singing career and that's okay i this is
my career
if i could turn bad time can't get that
bloody song out of my mind
since my visit bookings at maison de
mesa have surged welcome to masano
mercia two for dinner
the new guests are enjoying the pool and
the new menus
were impressive i didn't even know this
place was here and kelly is learning how
to be a proper general manager i
appreciate you coming you're welcome
thank you i really am very grateful the
man knows what he's doing thank god for
gordon ramsay